it's been almost eight years since you
often live took over the helm of team
germany there have been plenty of
highlights at that time but is yet no
title and this world cup looks set to be
the toughest tournament of moves career
proceedings we all know the playing
conditions in Brazil are quite different
from here no European team has ever won
a title playing in South America so
giving a kickoff x ug unusual for us 1
p.m. or 4pm right and of course the
temperatures could be different than the
ones we used to hear improve and feel
light as we as yogi warns in the team
slogan going into Brazil is ready ER
than ever and that's the image they're
putting forward in promotional ads like
this one for adidas but some older
players are worried about missing their
last chance in World Cup victory in to
come on we're putting some of the
pressure on ourselves we've been really
successful in the last tournaments and
when you always make it to the
semi-final pressures there oak Bob
Captain Philipp Lahm is still fighting
for full fitness as as keeper Manuel
Neuer and Bastian Schweinsteiger fellow
midfielder sami khedira still needs more
match practice following a knee injury
that kept him off the pitch for six
months still Koechner is counting on him
Sammy Sammy is in good health and
physical condition after recovering from
such a long injury Ward akiza laughs a
little but there are even more
challenges facing move germany's defense
is patchy and midfielders like mezzo
goozoo have failed to produce consistent
results loof appears undecided on
offense sometimes deploying veteran
miroslav klose up the only real striker
in the squad or relying solely on
midfielders but he does say one thing is
going right thus sir I was conquer we're
seeing a competitor's turn into
teammates and lone wolves turn into team
players now even team player Verdun
but that won't be enough to save lives
job without a World Cup title for
Germany his days as coach could be
numbered